[Music]
anything is possible in Rosewood right
Jay Mitchell dishing on those PLL
spin-off rumors Sasha Pieterse does
ballroom announcement and everything you
need to know about her new lifetime
series it's an adaptation on lifetime
call to you live is that the perfect
post PLL project for you it's juicy it
still has all those elements that PLL
have with it being you know sort of a
mystery there's a romance part to it and
it's just it's exciting it's based off
of a book series yeah I've good luck
with that in the past it's it deals with
a lot of crazy things like PLL did but
it's a different storyline if you love a
PL out you're gonna absolutely love you
and if you never stop you know you're
still gonna love you how would you
describe the peach she is known to be
not the nicest so she is called a mean
girl but you know she does have a love
for Beck he's the main character and
you'll see that she has a very
interesting relationship with her I feel
like peach seems so different than Emily
field was that exciting and enticing to
you 100% peach is the complete 180 from
what Emily was and I actually catch
myself sometimes cuz I feel bad you know
I'll say my line that's written for me
I'm just like in this family but it's
fun it's so fun I'm getting to shoot on
location in New York so that's also
really exciting I'm moving here are you
relocating here now for a little bit
yeah I'm a little New Yorker can you
tell me about working with and Badgley
on this show and were you a Gossip Girl
fans I don't know anybody that wasn't a
Gossip Girl fan you know me and my
friends loved watching it um 10 is so
hilarious and he's so funny he's a goof
on set even though he plays you know a
serious character and we have just a lot
of fun some big exciting news sasha is
going to be I'm dancing with a star I am
so excited sasha was like is the best
secret keeper she truly did not tell any
of us she told us there was something on
the works or something we had no idea so
I'm so excited for her
we expect to see you in the ballroom
matter at all cheering her I will be
more than happy to be sitting front row
screaming the loudest for Sasha hundred
percent yeah and lastly Pretty Little
Liars spin-off update do you have one to
share with me um I have no idea I mean
anything is possible in Rosewood right
that's not enough you know me I'm a good
secret keeper - so you'll have to find
out